S Stéphanie Grandmont,
MiMichel C. Auger et Alec
CaCastonguay, bonsoir.
JeJe vous fais entendre de cours
exextraits d'Emmanuel Macron ete
MaMadame Le Pen hier. Tout de
susuite après le dévoilement de
rérésultats.
EMEMMANUEL MACRON, candidat élu
àà la présidentielle française
- - Je sais aussi que nombre de
nonos compatriotes ont voté ce
jojour pour moi. Non pour souter
leles idées que je porte, mais
popour faire barrage à celle
dede l'extrême droite.
(a(applaudissements)
EtEt je veux aussi les remercier
etet leur dire que j'ai consciee
quque ce vote m'oblige pour
leles années à venir.
MAMARINE LE PEN
chcheffe, Rassemblement national
- - En dépit de deux semaines
dede méthodes déloyales, brutals
etet violentes, similaire à cels
quque vivent au quotidien les
FrFrançais. Les idées que nous
rereprésentons arrivent à des
sosommets, un soir de second tor
dede l'élection présidentielle.
AvAvec plus de 43 % des voix,
lele résultat de ce soir
rereprésente en lui-même
unune éclatante victoire.
- - Voilà. Je pense que c'est un
trtrès bon résumé du temps de
chchaque côté. Madame Le Pen qui
didit qu'elle est mieux voir le
veverre à moitié plein. Jamais n
momouvement n'a obtenu autant, 3
%.%. Et Monsieur Macron qui dit:
jeje vous entends, il y a une
frfracture sociale. Tous n'ont s
vovoté pour moi. Stéphanie, tour
dede table, réflexion sur ce
rérésultat assez net et clair.
- - Ce n'est pas un triomphe, ms
lala victoire est claire.
OnOn peut se réjouir parce queue
quque je pense, c'est une victoe
popour l'Europe, pour l'Ukraine.
EtEt par ricochet, une victoire
popour le Canada. Mais ce n'est
papas un triomphe. Monsieur Macn
vava avoir énormément de travaià
fafaire pour recoudre les
momorceaux. Il hérite d'une Frae
dédéchirée. Est libéré et d'une
EuEurope déchirée par la guerre.
EtEt tout ça ne va pas se recoue
dudu jour au lendemain.
SiSi Marine Le Pen est si forte,
efeffectivement, elle n'a jamais
eueu un résultat aussi élevé,
c'c'est parce qu'il y a une
frfracture en France. Et ça ne
pepeut pas être balayé en dessos
dudu tapis. Évidemment, la
ququestion en Ukraine, c'est lon
d'd'être simple. On sait que
MoMonsieur Macron s'était préseé
cocomme un médiateur de
prprédilection, un interlocuteur
dede prédilection avec Vladimir
PoPoutine. Il va pouvoir reprene
lala où il avait laissé il y a
dedeux semaines pour se consacrr
àà sa campagne électorale.
EsEst-ce que ç ça veut dire qu'y
auaura des résultats à ces effos
didiplomatiques? Peut-être pas.
MaMais la France est quand même
bibien placée pour agir en ce
sesens. Monsieur Macron à la
lélégitimité parce qu'il a la
prprésidence de l'union européee
jujusqu'en juillet. Et la Franca
totoujours été un peu un acteur,
unun pays qui se présentait come
unune puissance indépendante, un
gegenre d'arbitre entre la Russe
etet les États-Unis.
- - Michel, 24 heures plus tard,
StStéphanie fait référence à cee
cocolère de Jean qui se sente
peperdant devant la
momondialisation. Des gens qui e
sese sentent pas en face de tout
avavec l'époque que Macron
inincarne. Il devra faire quelqe
chchose. Il devra, sinon, cette
popolarisation va s'accentuer.
- - Je pense que Monsieur Macron
dadans son premier mandat n'a ps
bibien réussi à comprendre quels
sosont les symboles qui touchait
seses électeurs. Par exemple,
ququand il a aboli très tôt dans
lele mandat la taxe sur les
grgrandes fortunes. Les
écéconomistes disent que ce n'et
papas une bonne taxe. Mais ça la
plplacé tout de suite comme un
prprésident des riches.
C'C'est ce genre de geste
auauxquelles il doit faire
atattention. Quand il y a eu lér
lélégende, ça a été créé par une
auaugmentation des prix du
pépétrole. Encore une fois, voii
ququelque chose pour les gens qi
vivivent dans les régions rurals
ququi ont besoin d'une voiture,l
nene l'a pas compris. C'est assz
dédétail la, parce que sur
l'l'ensemble de la politique, il
n'n'y a pas trop de problèmes.
C'C'est toutes les petites choss
ququi peuvent aller chercher un
sesecteur de la population de
fafaçon très précise, il faut
ququ'il fasse attention à ça.
CeCe n'est pas les économistes i
vovont voter aux législatives le
momois prochain ou à la prochaie
cacampagne électorale. C'est les
cicitoyens.
- - 24 heures plus tard, on voit
nénéanmoins, oui, elle n'a jamas
étété aussi forte Madame Le Pen,
mamais il y a comme un plafond e
veverre. On sent que ses idées
d'd'extrême droite plafonnent.
- - Il ne faut pas présumer que
totout le monde a voté pour le
prprogramme de Marine Le Pen non
plplus. Il faut contextualiser n
prprenant en compte le système
frfrançais. Imaginait ICV qu'on
auaurait un système où le premir
miministre était élu au suffrage
ununiversel et qu'on avait un
sesecundo, on se serait retrouvé
avavec un affrontement entre
JuJustin Trudeau et Erin O'Tool.
CoCorey fait les partisans du
PaParti vert? Certains se serait
raralliés à Justin Trudeau en
didisant que c'est un moindre m.
IlIl y en a d'autres qui auraiet
vovoté à n'importe qui sauf Jusn
TrTrudeau pour lui envoyer un
memessage. Il y en a certainemet
ququi ont fait ça avec Marine Le
PePen, pour envoyer un message.
EsEst-ce que tout le monde
apappuyait les idées de Marine e
PePen dans les 41 %? Probablemet
papas non plus. Je pense qu'il a
dedes gens qui ont voté aussi pr
MaMarine Le Pen en sachant qu'ee
n'n'allait pas être élue, mais i
enenvoyait un message aux élites
frfrançaises. Il faut le mettre
auaussi dans le contexte. Elle a
fafait une bonne performance.
EsEst-ce que ça veut dire que
l'l'extrême droite est rendue à
plplus de 40 %? Je ne pense pas.
- - Un des prochains tests, c'et
leles législatives, en deux
ététapes. C'est à une semaine
d'd'intervalle, les 12 et 19
jojoints. On va voir si les viex
papartis arrivent à faire voter
asassez de députés pour faussere
jejeu. Ce sera très intéressant.
- - Ce sera intéressant parce qe
çaça va confirmer ou infirmer la
momort des deux grands partis qi
s's'étaient échangés le pouvoir
pependant 40 ans, les socialists
etet les républicains, les
gagaullistes. Ils ont eu dans
cecertains cas, les socialistes
onont eu à peine de quoi formern
paparti politique reconnu, 25
dédéputés. Mais la majajorité de
MoMonsieur Macron avait été
tetellement grande lors des
lélégislatives il y a cinq ans,n
dodoute qu'il puisse répéter cee
mamajorité. Il faudra savoir oùa
s's'en va. Est-ce que ça s'en và
l'l'extrême droite ou pas?
EsEst-ce qu'ils vont vouloir vor
dede la même façon aux
lélégislatives qui l'ont fait au
prprésidentiel? Ce n'est pas
cecertain. Il faut que Monsieur
MaMacron est une majorité à
l'l'Assemblée nationale, sinon
c'c'est un gouvernement de
cocohabitation. C'est toujours
dédésagréable pour le président.
- - On ferme le tour de table sr
l'l'importance des législatives.
- - Ça va être intéressant de vr
çaça. Macron a comme un peu fait
lele vide autour de lui dans les
paparties traditionnelles. Maisn
a a quand même constaté au premr
totour des présidentielles il ya
5555 % des Français qui ont voté
popour des extrêmes, que ce soit
lala gauche radicale ou l'extrêe
drdroite. Ça montre quand même
cecette France qui est écartelé.
CoComment ça va se traduire au
niniveau législatif? Ce sera
inintéressant. Une chose est
cecertain, Macron qui avait pros
d'd'éviter les dérives
exextrémistes, c'est un constat
d'd'échec pour l'instant.
- - J'ai hâte de voir comment vt
sese débrouiller les deux grands
papartis traditionnels parce
ququ'ils sont généralement mieux
ororganisés dans les régions etu
niniveau local, ils détiennent s
mamairies, des régions. Ils sont
bibien implantés. Ils ont encore
lolocalement un peu de ressort t
j'j'ai hâte de voir si ce ressot
s's'est brisé ou saisissant ence
cacapable de faire élire un
cecertain nombre de députés, por
jujustement tenir tête à Emmanul
MaMacron. Pour avoir une positin
unun peu plus forte que ce qu'oa
dédémontré lors de la course
prprésidentielle. Ce n'est -1
coconcours de personnalité.
OnOn va voir si les grands parts
onont encore un peu de gaz danse
réréservoir.
- - De reformer une gauche et de
dedevenir le premier ministre de
MaMacron. Twitter, Elon Musk
ququi a organisé un montage
fifinancier gigantesque et qui,
popour 44 milliards, s'empare de
totoute l'entreprise. Je vous fs
lilire une partie de son tweet.
IlIl plaide depuis des semainest
dedes semaines que Twitter est
trtrop contraignant, qu'on a bré
lala liberté d'expression, qu'on
n'n'aurait pas dû exclure M.
TrTrump. Que Twitter doit diffur
totoutes les opinions de tout le
spspectre politique. Donc il dit
ququ'il va montrer comment il va
fafaire ça et il achète tout.
QuQu'est-ce que ça veut dire sur
lala suite des choses?
- - Si l'avenir du débat
huhumanitaire repose sur Twitte,
onon est vraiment mal parti. Pae
ququ'en 240 caractères, ça ne ft
papas des débats très profonds.
C'C'était un peu grandiloquent
cocomme tweet. Sa prise de
poposition va à l'encontre de ce
quque les gouvernements sont en
trtrain d'essayer de faire à
trtravers la planète, c'est-à-de
lélégiférer pour que ces géants
sosoient au contraire plus
imimpliqué dans la gestion de lr
alalgorithme, de l'expérience ds
ututilisateurs pour qu'il y ait
momoins de à et de désinformati.
OnOn l'a vu au Canada et en
EuEurope. Et même aux États-Uni,
bebeaucoup de questionnements
popolitiques sur ces les plates-
foformes devraient être davantae
reredevables. Est-ce qu'on devrt
cocontrôler sur Facebook ou
InInstagram? Parce qu'il se dit
n'n'importe quoi. Il dit qu'on a
papas la liberté d'expression
ququ'on devrait. Je me demande i
onon ne va pas avoir un court-
cicircuit entre ce qu'il souhaie
fafaire et ce que souhaitent les
gogouvernements de la planète.
LeLes utilisateurs aussi débarqs
dede ces réseaux parce qu'ils ne
sese sentent plus les bienvenus.
EsEst-ce que ça prend plus de
liliberté d'expression ou est-ce
ququ'il ne faut pas davantage
enencadrer? Ça va souper
cecertainement ce débat.
- - Si on met des paramètres, on
l'l'avait évoqué quand 30 a été
gegelés, qui décide? Trame, c'et
unune évidence après le 6 janvi,
l'l'assaut au Capitole. Mais qui
esest juge de la bonne pensée?
C'C'est un peu l'argument de Eln
MuMusk. Il dit que ce n'est pasn
CaCalifornie qu'on doit décider
ququel était l'idée a droit d'êe
enentendu.
- - Effectivemenent. Elon Musk t
unun libertarien, pour lui, toue
cocontrainte n'est pas bonne.
CÇa a été pas mal payant dans sn
cacas. Un moment donné, on s'est
rerendu compte que Twitter pouvt
seservir de véhicule à des idées
ququi seraient répréhensibles ms
dadangereuses. Des fois, ça peut
crcréer des mouvements de foules
ququi ne sont pas très bon. C'et
lala première chose. La deuxième
chchose, c'est qu'il a payé 44
mimilliards pour ça. Il n'y a rn
ququi tombe plus vite qu'un résu
sosocial. Êtes-vous sur TikTok?l
paparaît que tout le monde est
rerendu là-dessus sauf nous.
C'C'est maintenant la grosse
afaffaire. Est-ce que Twitter va
êêtre encore la grosse affaire
dadans un an? Je ne peux pas vos
lele dire.
- - Mes enfants le sont,
j'j'imagine. Ma fille va rire de
momoi. Stéphanie, Elon Musk mais
bebeaucoup d'argent. Oui, c'est
l'l'homme le plus riche de la
plplanète, mais c'est un montage
fifinancier énorme. Il n'a pas
enenvie de tout perdre. Qu'est-e
ququ'il veut faire avec ça? Este
quque ça vous fait peur?
- - D'abord, je trouve cela
paparticulièrement ironique
d'd'entendre Elon Musk se placer
cocomme le grand défenseur de la
liliberté d'expression parce que
lului-même, on sait qu'il est
plplutôt... il ne voit pas la
crcritique d'un très bon oeil.
DoDonc, les employés qui
trtravaillent pour lui doit sigr
unun accord de non divulgation.
IlIls ne peuvent pas faire aucue
plplainte à l'extérieur de
l'l'entreprise sans quoi il se
reretrouve devant un arbitre.
C'C'est très contraignant.
LuLui-même ne prend pas la
crcritique trop bien. Et puis,
efeffectivement, les médias
sosociaux, éventuellement, on et
plplus en mode où on veut les
enencadrer. Parce que tout ce qi
sese dit et parfois assez
dédérangeant. Et les résultats,e
n'n'est pas seulement des
babanalités. On a vu avec le
scscandale de Cambridge
ananalytiqca, à quel point ça pt
avavoir un résultat sur les
élélections. On l'a vu avec
l'l'élection de Donald Trump. Je
meme demande si Elon Musk à cete
sesensibilité, lui qui a fait un
paparallèle extrêmement douteux
ququand il y a eu le convoi de a
liliberté à Ottawa. Il a comparé
JuJustin Trudeau à Hitler.
C'C'est un drôle d'apôtre de la
liliberté d'expression.
- - Le danger, dans cette veine,
c'c'est que ça peut devenir un
poporte-voix énorme pour les ges
ququi se construisent leur réalé
paparce qu'ils sont mécontents s
rérésultats électoraux. Ce n'est
papas ce que Madame Le Pen a fat
totout à fait. Quoiqu'elle a dit
ququ'il y avait eu de la
mamalhonnêteté. C'est un conduit
popour amplifier des réactions à
lala trempe.
- - Il y a 40 % des Américains i
crcroient que l'élection a été
vovolée, l'élection de M. Trump.
CÇa fait presque deux ans. Il ny
a a pas eu une seule voix dont n
a a prouvé devant un juge qui a
étété déposé de façon illégale.0
% % des gens croient ça parce qe
DoDonald Trump le 10. Et leur
plplate-forme préférée est
TwTwitter. Un moment donné, où l
y y a un danger d'amplificatione
fafausses nouvelles et de
mamanipulation des gens qui est
énénorme. Et dire qu'on ne modèe
plplus à du tout, on pourra dire
cece qu'on veut, c'est la liberé
d'd'expression, ce n'est peut-êe
papas la liberté d'expression.
- - Quoi ajouter à cela sinon qe
lolorsqu'on a 44 milliards danse
fofond de sa poche et qu'on peut
sese payer un réseau social, je
trtrouve ça assez particulier.
PePeut-être qu'il devra recadrer
unun peu ses discours.
- - Ça fait beaucoup d'argent si
jajamais ça s'effondre. Même por
lului.
- - Il a emprunté la 44 000 000
00000.
- - Sa valeur et de 200 quelques
mimilliards. Il a créé un
coconsortium de banques qui lui
prprêtent de l'argent.
UnUn mot sur l'enquête à Ottawa.
C'C'est dans la loi des mesures
d'd'urgence. Ils sont obligés de
lalancer une enquête. C'est un
jujuge à la retraite qui va
prprésider l'enquête. C'est
rarassurant de voir qu'on va qud
mmême examiner sous toutes ses
cocoutures le recours à cette li
d'd'urgence. Tour de table.
- - En plus, ce juge va avoir le
popouvoir d'assigner des témoin,
dede réclamer des documents, une
vévéritable commission d'enquêt.
C'C'est très bien. Est-ce que ce
sesera public? Je n'ai pas troué
lala précision à quel point on a
popouvoir assister à tout ça. Ms
onon va aller au fond des chose.
CeCe sera la première fois qu'on
enenquête sur l'utilisation de a
loloi. Que les choses soient bin
fafaites au départ, ce sera
imimportant. On aura un modèle r
lelesquels s'appuyer pour savoir
cece qu'on peut améliorer comme
réréglementation ou resserrée
cocomme boulons pour que ce soit
mimieux utilisé. C'est très
imimportant.
- - La question essentielle, c't
: : est-ce que la loi était
esessentielle ou utile? Tout le
momonde a dit qu'elle était uti,
mamais était-elle essentielle? l
fafaut que le juge réponde à ça.
- - Ça aurait été très utile
d'd'avoir ça en 1970. Il y a
enencore des rumeurs qui circult
susur toutes sortes de
mamalversations qui seraient
ararrivées. On ne le sait pas
paparce qu'on n'a pas eu d'enque
cocomme ça. Et de dire voici
ququ'elle demande le gouvernemet
a a reçu, ce n'est pas encore
clclair dans les jours qui ont
prprécédé l'évocation de la loi,
memettre ça au clair et une très
bobonne idée.
- - Les deux grandes questions
auauxquelles il va falloir
rérépondre : est-ce qu'il y avat
unune question de sécurité
nanationale qui était en jeu? Ce
n'n'est pas clair. On a trouvé s
ararmes à un certain moment,
d'd'accord, mais est-ce que la
sésécurité nationale était en j?
CeCe sera avoir. Deuxième questn
: : est-ce que les lois
prprovinciales étaient
ininsuffisantes pour régler le
prproblème? Encore là, ce n'est
papas clair. On sait qu'à Québe,
lele maire marchant a réussi à
fafaire en sorte que le convoi e
prprenne pas racine. On avait vu
jujuste avant qu'à Windsor, on
avavait réussi à débloquer le
popont. Est-ce qu'on aurait pu y
ararriver à Ottawa sans ces
memesures? C'est possible. Je
pepense que la loi a quand même
étété utile parce que ça a
fofonctionné. Clairement, on
auaurait préféré ne pas en arrir
llà. Mais on va voir les
rérésultats de l'enquête et ça a
êêtre intéressant justement
d'd'avoir tout ce processus. Ça
momontre que c'est une loi bien
didifférente que celle des mesus
dede guerre. Il y a des gens qui
avavaient fait des parallèles,
mamais ce n'est pas la même cho.
- - Elle a été passablement
adadoucie depuis la première
momouture. Merci beaucoup à vous
tr